hello everyone and welcome to some big
news from the singfield cup round six
and also uh maybe even possible uh
greater news from the F candid
tournament 2024 it's Anish giri versus
ler Dominguez Perez and let's just check
out the game first and then we're going
to discuss what is possible and what
isn't H so Anish had the white pieces
and he opened with Pawn to G3 this is
the soc called Kings fetto opening and
we have C5 by uh by lener sort of
inviting an to go for a Sicilian Defense
if he plays Pawn to E4 and we kind of
get that Anish goes for Bishop to G2
Knight to C6 and now Pawn to E4 and it
this something called The lasard Dun
attack where uh it's a bit of a
different move order but imagine that
white played E4 black played C5 white
played Pawn to G3 black played Knight to
C6 and white played Bishop to G2 so a
very weird move order for the Sicilian
but it is possible to play and of course
there is a lot of theory behind it pawn
to G6 preparing to Fan to the dark
Square Bishop going for for a sort of a
dragon setup Here pawn to D3 Bishop to
G7 and now Pawn to F4 we have Pawn to D6
uh and now Knight to H3 now this is very
very rare the only player to ever play
this on the absolute top level is none
other than rard raport but of course we
do expect that from him usually Knight
to F3 is played here and there are quite
a lot of games with this position but
after Knight H3 not so many Pawn to H5
even less Knight to F2 and now Pawn to
E5 and here there is there are I think
two games where C3 was played uh but
here we have Knight to C3 and it is now
already as of move eight that we have a
completely new game so let's see what
laner had in mind we have Knight to F6
Pawn to H3 taking away the G4 Square
from Black's pieces and now Bishop to H6
and this is a a really fine move um uh
because uh you don't just play
automatically because usually you just
want to continue developing like Bishop
D6 or you Castle or you maybe uh develop
the queen something but Bishop to H6
moving a piece that you already moved
once and from G7 that is a natural
Square for the bishop uh this is uh well
definitely requires a top player to to
play such a move we have Knight D2 by an
Nish adding a Defender to F4 and also
preparing maybe C3 and D4 in the future
and now Knight to D4 saying okay if you
kick my KN away I'm just going to
capture here or I might even go back uh
we have castles first and now laner goes
Knight back to E6 and here we have the
first very interesting moment in the
game where Anish has the option of
playing F5 as the Knight on E6 now
blocks the bishop covering the F5 square
but you have to calulate do you want to
do it so it's not that difficult to
calulate I'm sure both of them uh were
able to do it fairly quickly uh so let's
just see what happens after F5 G
captures on F5 Bishop captures on H6
Rook captures and now e captures on F5
the Knight will go after the bishop
along with after the pawn along with the
bishop You'll Play G4 H captures H
captures now threatening G5 with a
double attack so the Knight has to move
and now you're going to shift the Knight
to C3 gain control over the center and
the game continues with white having
somewhat an open King but a very very uh
strong position so it's uh it's great
for both white and black basically uh
but Anish probably thought that uh as
alir play played played this that he is
welcoming it so maybe he decided against
it and he played F captures on E5
instead of going for the advancement uh
we have Bishop captures on C1 Queen
captures and now D captures on E5 and
now uh how do you uh continue this do
you go Knight to C3 no uh he keeps the
Knight here to help out with the defense
of the king side Anish plays Knight back
to D1 now he can bring this Knight over
to D5 if needed or maybe even to E3 and
then F5 and D5 uh in the future so Pawn
to H4 alir continues his uh Onslaught on
the king Side Pawn to G4 and now Pawn to
G5 we have Knight E3 as the F5 Square
now has been been vacated so he can even
choose between Knight to D5 and Knight
to F5 and Knight to F4 H okay you have
to uh give something to take something
and now Queen to E1 you could also trade
but that would only improve Black's
position after G captures an F4 so Queen
to E1 defending the Knight here and
Bishop to E6 uh we have Knight captures
on F4 uh G captures so now he decided to
actually go for this the Knight to F5
and Bishop captures on F5 we have e
captures and here we reach uh the a
second very important moment in the game
where uh black has to decide what to
play and it's not easy uh if you just
play uh if you just play nothing and you
allow something like Rook to D1 C3 D4 or
B4 then white will s all of his problems
but by playing Queen to D4 check first
lener ensures that Anish is never to
able to execute this C3 Pawn push so the
king now has to move uh King to H1 was
played and queenside Castle adding more
supports to pressure the D3 Pawn here so
Queen to A5 going after the A7 pawn and
just King to B8 and now Rook a to E1 and
here we have Rook H to E8 going after
the B2 Pawn of course makes no sense
after Rook to B1 you can resign the B7
Pawn will fall and you're going to get
checkmated so after Rook 81 Rook H to E8
was played and now we have Pawn to C3
here uh the best way for to play this
for Anish is to play Rook e two and wait
for black to do something then play Pawn
to B3 maybe maybe even later on Pawn to
A3 and B4 but not not rush anything just
um give black the move and wait for
black to do something and then you can
Shi the queen back to E1 once you've uh
defended everything on the queen side so
really slow playing this is the way but
Anish went Pawn to C3 he wants to trade
the D3 Pawn for the C5 Pawn uh but here
uh he also allows lineer to grab control
over the G3 Square uh so let's see what
happens Queen captures on D3 Anish
captures on C5 and now we have Queen to
G3 with sort of a pretty big threat what
happens if you if you just play
something let's say play Pawn to B4 well
the idea is Rook D2 with the threat of
Checkmate and of course you can't move
the bishop otherwise you get checkmated
here or even even here and if you play
Rook to G1 to stop Checkmate now E4 and
then F3 and the white just resigns this
so Anish has to go back with the queen
he played Queen to F2 uh even better
would be Rook to D1 but uh this is
already a very complicated position he
played Queen to f to and ler now uh
decided to trade as his position is
completely winning but it's very
important to see why the queen trade is
a completely winning here uh you guys
will be the judge of that so okay
captures captures was played feel free
to pause the video now and find the
absolute best continuation and the only
winning one for ler uh while I give you
a couple of
seconds so for those of you who were
able to do it congrat congratulations on
always being a true Master of the end
game and for those of you who just want
to enjoy the show it is Knight the H7
that's right it's always a move with the
Knight back and you know whenever you
have a position always imagine your
knight going back as often the case is
that that is the strongest move and the
problem with this now for white is uh
what do you play uh let's not forget
black has two connected pass pawns but
what do you play here if you play let's
say you play Rook F back to F1 you want
to claim the D file or something uh F6
black doesn't even have to rush anything
let's say you play Rook D1 okay black
will will even trade captures captures
and now just Knight to G5 and this is an
eternal weakness F3 is coming then E4 E3
is coming and black just pushes the
pawns and wins the game so it's that
simple so Anish tried Pawn to F6 he
tried to uh he tried to talk a linear
into capturing the F6 Pawn just to buy
sometime before the Knight reaches the
G5 Square liner says no I'm not taking
that I'm going to G E5 and he will go
for the pawn after The Rook so Bishop to
E4 uh Anish even tries to give up this
strong Bishop for the Knight battling
here not interested he just goes Knight
Rook to D6 he doesn't even want to
capture on H3 uh he just wants to
improve his position as much as possible
because Anish has no way of taking care
of all of the weaknesses in the position
King to G2 now even King to C7 again not
rushing it Bishop to F5 now even King to
d8 I do not understand this King to d8
move uh you have to be obviously a
player of Lanier's strength to to play
such a move but he played it King to d8
now comes Pawn to B4 and now Rook
captures on F6 we have Rook to D2 with
check now the King goes back King to C7
so like I said I have no idea why he put
the King on
d8 uh Rook to D7 with check King to B8
and now Pawn to C4 Anish starts marching
forward with those Queens side pawns uh
E4 laner responds by advancing the Pawns
in the center C5 Now Pawn to E3 we have
King to F1 Now Pawn to A6 we have Rook
to D6 offering a rook trade and now
while capturing on D6 is still winning
for lener he decides to uh to finish the
game in great style Rook captures on F5
uh G captures on F5 now Knight to F3 not
even going for H3 laner is a true Class
Act in this game not capturing any
unnecessary material just going for what
is what is um correct so like Bruce Lee
in the quote Above The Bard
uh Rook to E2 and now Rook to E4 uh we
have Pawn to A3 defending the B4 Pawn
here H but now just Knight to E5 the
Knight now moves and the DF Pawn will
start marching forward we have Rook to
C2 Pawn to
F3 uh Rook to C1 not much you can do
here Rook to C4 offering a rook trade
even uh green to be down the exchange
but the pawns are too strong uh Rook D1
was played Rook to C3 now again not
rushing anything Rook to d8 with check
King to to C7 Rook to E8 going after the
Knight Pawn to E2 with check and now
that is just a game over King F2 Knight
to D3 with check wins The Rook for the
two pawns here so King captures on F3
Knight captures on E1 King captures on
E2 and now Knight to G2 with the Rook
going after the H3 Pawn next or by
Knight F4 check you're going to capture
it this way so doesn't really matter
Rook E7 check was played King to C6 now
Rook captures an F7 Anish also creates a
pass Pawn H but now Knight to F4 with
check King D2 attacks The Rook here now
Rook captures on H3 and Rook to F6 with
check King to D5 Rook to D6 with check
King to E5 and now Pawn to F6 hoping to
get F7 and f8 in but of course just Rook
to F3 uh F7 was played by Anish but now
Knight to E6 and he was in this position
on move 56 that Anish giri resigned the
game as there is nothing more to be done
here so um you resign as the queening
square is guarded twice and there is no
defense you're just going to Capt the
pawn or if white persists in playing
this Rook to F7 then you just Advance
theh Pawn and it's um even if King D2
you can even give up The Rook doesn't
matter just H2 captures now H1 comes
with check of course black is completely
winning here so brilliant brilliant game
by lineer Dominguez Perez who drew five
of his first games in the singfield cup
2023 and now takes a win over Anish giri
and remember Anish giri is still
fighting for that spot in the candidates
tournament and this game could make it a
problem for him because um look at this
look at what happened now uh let me just
uh make this a little bit smaller so
look at what happened uh lineer jumped
up six spots so he he jumped from number
13 to number seven and he overtook alza
he overtook kakin he overtook aniri he
overtook Anand he overtook makulu uh so
uh a lot of people that he overtook and
which is very important uh Wesley so is
still uh uh do doing better than him but
it doesn't matter uh because wesle so is
also leading the FED circuit so there
are two more spots that you can qualify
for the fiday candidates tournament 2024
one is the Fay circuit that will finish
in December and one is uh the highest
rating as of January 2024 so if Wesley
so qualifies via the fetus circuit then
it will be possible for ler Dominguez
Perez to qualify via the highest rating
because all of the other uh players in
front of him are already either
qualified or unable to play play as they
are world champion or refusing to play
if they are Magnus Carlson so big big
news for lener Dominguez Perez who uh if
he continues um strongly and if he
doesn't lose he will get his spot in the
fed cander this tournament but as I
understand it he will also play uh he
will also have to play an additional
tournament uh as he had he does not have
enough games um in 2023 because you also
have to have a certain amount of games
you can't just like if you have a rating
of 2800 you can't just be hogging your
rating and uh you know claim the
candidate spot you have to play a
certain amount of games I think the
number is 33 but I I could be wrong uh
so yeah that's the news regarding the
candidates tournament hope you enjoyed
it and yeah brilliant brilliant game by
Anish GE he went for this slow opening
this slow Sicilian with uh with the G3
and Bishop to G2 the last cun attack but
um ler proved that he is not one that
gets the prised easily and he uh
dominated pretty much the entire game
especially after this queen to D4 move
this was just uh a master class after
this uh Queen to D4 move it was just it
was just all L A and really an an
exemplary game that we can all uh enjoy
and learn from uh so yeah that's the
game hope you guys enjoyed it I would
like to wish a very happy birthday to
Chrystal Salim and I would like to thank
David gasparian Karim kawash Muhammad
Solan and David David Anthony for a
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot I really appreciate it as usual you
can check to my previous videos thank
you for watching and I will see you soon
continuing the coverage of everything
that's happening in the Chess World and
of course checking up on your guys
suggestions as I usually do uh so thank
you all I will see you soon and have an
excellent rest of your
day